the Greek gods were awful right they
were they were well they were like older
brothers and sisters I was a middle
child and so I feel this very very
keenly they were bigger and you know
faster and stronger and you know they
never died and they were you know they
were they were more powerful but if you
if you try to be like them if you aspire
to be like them they turn around and
slap you down right
spoken as a little sister and so at best
they were unreliable uh-huh and so it's
not surprising that in trying to answer
this question of how do we make
ourselves matter in this world what can
we do in order to achieve a life worth
living
are we born into mattering is there
something we have to do or be in order
to achieve mattering the Greeks didn't
turn to their religion those gods never
made one feel particularly as if one
mattered you didn't want to attract the
attention of the gods nothing good ever
happened if you attract the attention of
the gods if in fact the way that we're
made to feel is if we matter there's a
lot to do with attracting attention
being feeling worthy of attention which
I do believe it does have to do with
then it's not a surprise that the Greeks
turn to the attention of one another in
order to achieve their sense of
mattering and not to their gods and so
the Greeks did they had what I call an
ethos of the extraordinary this was
their way of trying to go about I was a
very secular way away a human way not a
not a mortal way not an immortal way of
trying to achieve their mattering and it
was did you do something big to achieve
something big and and be extraordinary
in some way and this
it's not philosophy yet but I would say
that it's it was created the
preconditions for a philosophy it was a
way of trying to think it out in very
very human terms
you